[Music]
thank you
earth's surface is more than 70 percent
water filling more than a billion cubic
kilometers
your body is more than 50 water
indeed life crawled out of the oceans
only after developing the capacity to
carry its own inner supply of water as
it Strode on dry land
water is so vital to life on Earth that
scientists anticipate that water May
well be the key to life anywhere
but what's the origin of all the water
on planet Earth
did water come from comets in the outer
reaches of the solar system that
bombarded the Earth not only with water
but with the complex molecules necessary
for life
could water have come from a much closer
Source the asteroid belt between Mars
and Jupiter or could both of these
sources have played a part
these questions animate the career of
Stephanie Milo the James Webb Space
telescope's Deputy project scientist for
planetary science
Milam uses the telescope to study the
astrophysical signatures of simple
molecules to explore our planetary
neighbors and seek clues for the origin
of water in the solar system
investigations that may prove pivotal to
finding evidence for life beyond Earth
welcome Stephanie it is great to see you
in person
we spoke at a distance some months ago I
was in Brisbane you were probably in
Washington D.C I would imagine so it's
nice to do this face-to-face now in
Brisbane you had
an astonishing image of the planet
Neptune and it's it's wonderful to
compare the web telescopes version of
that with Hubble it really gives a feel
for the advance if we bring up the image
so tell us what we're seeing so this is
the Hubble telescope version of Neptune
um beautiful blue planet it's our most
distant planet
um and you can see some dark spots on
Neptune with Hubble Space Telescope uh
those are Cloud features so we actually
get clouds that um just like we have
here on Earth um and weather and storms
and things that occur on these ice
giants in the outer solar system
um it's blue because it's uh
predominantly methane which which is
very reflective at blue colors so
um and then the James Webb Space
Telescope version we're at infrared
wavelengths so we're looking at mostly
thermal emission
um and again you can see the clouds here
in Neptune's atmosphere they're very
white and bright in this particular
image and that's because those clouds
are really high in the stratosphere and
the icy particles are very reflective at
these wavelengths and so they appear
very very bright but the most notable
feature is obviously the Rings and The
Rings are I'm calling jwst now the the
ring machine
it is extremely sensitive to dust and
Ice which is what the Rings are mostly
made of and so having access to these in
ways that we hadn't had before without
the Voyager Mission
um is is absolutely revolutionary and
we're so excited about the science
coming out of the ice giants with James
Webb now another ice giant a little bit
nearer to us is your newest yes so this
is the Hubble version of Uranus again
beautiful ice cap this is uh the
northern polar cap
it's uh again you can see a couple of
little white specks across the surface
those are other clouds again
um not very uh prominently seeing any
other features satellites Rings or
otherwise but if we go to the jwst
version
uh the ring machine
[Laughter]
again we have a fantastic perspective so
this is actually this the northern
spring so which lasts how long on Uranus
uh it's about 20 years so Uranus orbits
every 84 years yeah so uh in two 2028
we'll be in Northern summer so that's
when the full cap is going to be totally
uh face on to the Sun so it's a great
vantage point that we caught it and it's
spring because we have this fantastic
perspective of the Rings
um 11 of the 13 no rings are known rings
are visible with the James Webb Space
Telescope the other two we will probably
be able to see when we do a longer
exposure and different wavelengths
they're much finer and they're on the
outside so and what was your what was
your reaction when you first saw this
holy cow
uh so I I work on the communications
team as well as with with the science
teams
and I get to review a lot of the images
before they're publicly released and
um a person on my team was
um received the data because she was
helping with the processing and
reduction of this particular object and
she came in my office and she closes the
door she's like you have to see it you
have to see it I was like uh-uh no way
there's no way I will be able to keep my
mouth shut about this image I know it's
going to be brilliant and there was a
issue with the observations that we
actually did so
um this is actually only two filters of
the four that were originally planned
for this observation
um so we wanted to do the same four
filters that we used for the Neptune
image
um those four filters reflect very
different light in very different ways
and show different features
um be it the ice or the dust and
otherwise
um and two of the filters actually
failed during this observation and they
weren't able to get it back in the queue
before just momentarily a failure it's
not yeah it's not that it was like a a
full failure failure it was
um we have to point on stars and it
missed the star because there was a
cosmic ray that hit the camera so so for
a cosmic ray no one gets fired I think
it's fired
um so there was a lot of discussion
going on about whether or not they were
going to release the first two filters
or wait until Uranus came back into the
jwst field of regard which wouldn't be
until this fall
so I really didn't want to see it before
then because if I had to see it in
January February when we took these data
and then sit until September October of
this year on this beautiful image I
would have gone berserk is that like
seeing the last episode of succession
but only the first 50 minutes or
something like that yes
as soon as it came across my desk and
I'm reviewing it to be released to the
world I was like I can't believe we've
held on to it this long this is the most
amazing thing so this is out there in
the public yeah this has been publicly
released yes all right so you can no
secrets today right so
um Uranus is an unusual planet for a
number of reasons one is it's like
tipped on its side relative to the
orbital the you know rotation plane of
the others why is that we don't know
uh we don't know why Uranus is on on its
side it's it's almost 90 degrees on it
on the axis
um which is why we get this beautiful
vantage point of seeing the whole ring
structure with the North Pole pointing
toward us
um is it a collision I mean is that the
fault on Earth's tilted axis there's
there's ways that um could this could
have happened
um there's a lot of interest in studying
the Dynamo of Uranus and understanding
it better so we hope to have a mission
which was actually prioritized for the
next decade for planetary science to
have an Orbiter and a probe go to this
planet
um which will teach us all kinds of
information it'll let us know more about
the magnetic field and the interior
structure
um how deep are the ice layers what how
big is the core of the planet
um as well as compositional studies
atmospheric studies Rings planets moons
whatever
um it'll all be a lot more revealing if
we can actually visit
now you mentioned jwst is a ring machine
but obviously there had to be rings for
it to be a machine that detects them so
why are rings so common or are they as
common as they seem from the two
examples
well so we have rings on our four giant
planets
um we have rings on
um even trans and neptunian objects that
we've detected
um and even with jwst we've now detected
them through um occultation science
which is where a small body passes in
front of a star and we can measure uh
the flux coming from it and we can
actually detect the rings with with
respect to the solid body we also detect
binaries and the outer solar system as
well in this with this technique
um we're even trying to detect rings and
other objects in the solar system and
I'll just let your imagination wander
how many other planets that we could
possibly be looking at and hunting for
rings
jwst can only see Mars on outward if
that gives you any hints whatsoever and
and and so
um that data is not yet been released
but presumably used we're working on it
wow Hard uh do we have any evidence for
I I presume it's too difficult to detect
but for extra solar system planets are
they
ringed in rings as well
um we don't have
we don't have evidence for them to be
rained but there's no reason to believe
that they wouldn't be so Rings formed as
part of the process of forming the
planet so it's like just this the gas
and dust comes together in a swirl and
you're left with yes yeah okay
um and the satellites also contribute to
the ring material uh some satellites uh
have what we believe to be oceans
underneath the surface and these are
known as ocean worlds and sometimes when
they spew out their material that also
contributes to Rings
um and that was one of our latest
findings that we released this past week
and can you give us a little more
insight on that absolutely so um one of
the most prominent ocean worlds that we
have definitive evidence of is Enceladus
which is a satellite of Saturn
um the Cassini Mission actually got to
fly around the saturnian system for over
a decade and do close flybys of a number
of its satellites through the Rings the
planet itself lots of amazing science
even still coming out from the Cassini
mission
and um Enceladus is is has always been
an intriguing body
um even with the flybys from the Voyager
days we knew that it was there was
something very peculiar about it it
definitely looked like this ice icy
World it has these huge sort of cracks
across the surface
um and a notable feature of Enceladus is
on the bottom are the Southern
Hemisphere there's uh these these
striped regions
um we call them the tiger stripes and
the Cassini mission was actually able to
detect uh Vapor coming from those tiger
striped regions and that was just more
definitive evidence not only based on
the magnetic field and other properties
of the satellite but that was even more
evidence that there was a liquid
um within the interior of the satellite
and they were able to do some
compositional analysis with the mass
spectrometer they found that it was
water as a dominant component but also
some other
um minor constituents as well and you
know the question of how much that was
actually contributing to the ring has
always been uh sort of a a game of
calculations and modeling and theory and
with jwst we actually got some
definitive evidence of how much of that
vapor is actually contributing to the
e-ring of Saturn
um so this is our fantastic science
result so I'll just tell you what you're
seeing here because it's not quite
obvious so the big square is the James
Webb Space Telescope instrument field of
view it's the near-infrared spectrometer
every little square that you see is has
a full spectrum associated with it so we
were able to get the full near infrared
Spectrum with every pixel that you see
across this whole image
Enceladus being at Saturn's distance is
actually quite small it's a it's a
pretty small moon in and of itself
compared to our own Moon and it is about
one and a half pixels in size as far as
the scale of that that satellite and how
big is Enceladus uh it's like 0.6 of our
moon I think
uh don't quote me on that one I don't
know these numbers very well uh but at
any rate so Enceladus is a tiny little
dot so we get this data in and the first
thing we do is we see this
almost continuous mess of Spectra and
you know the pi and and myself and
another colleague were sitting there and
we're like ah what's this contamination
in the instrument what's going on this
is just really annoying because we're
gonna have to dig through and figure out
what the systematic error is that's
causing this flux to be everywhere well
it it's real that's all water vapor
um that extends uh multiple lunar
distances away from the actual Moon not
lunar distances and solid just distances
um and it's a it's a massive amount of
water and it it's everywhere water is
everywhere in this observation and in
fact it would extend even further if we
had actually offset the spectrometer to
do another map below it
um and we actually got time next year to
go back to this Target and do more
mapping and more compositional studies
and much deeper uh levels so hopefully
we'll have new detections of new
molecules
so um what you're seeing here now is
so our observation is this tiny little
square up in the top
um and we are able to extract the
spectrum of each one of these pixels so
we know how much of a spectrum is
actually coming from the plume itself
versus how much is actually in this
Taurus that's in the e-ring and we we
were able to determine that a
considerable almost all of the water in
that ring is actually from Enceladus
um a little bit of it goes onto Saturn
itself
um and that's just through the the
dynamic process of the satellite system
but uh this was just an absolutely
astonishing surprise and being able to
see with this kind of resolution the
outer solar system and characterize the
Rings the plumes of these bodies is is
just absolutely
um one of my favorite science results to
date yeah so far it's a stunning
achievement and it brings to mind
the question of water which I'd love to
jump off from this to turn to and then
some questions about this I'll come back
to at the end but
life on planet Earth couldn't exist
without water so obviously one of the
big questions is where does the water
come from
um
we physicists can give you an answer to
where the ingredients for the water
comes from we understand relatively well
and Professor Peebles has given us some
insight into that regarding you know
early on we understand
nucleosynthesis the formation of
hydrogen and helium we understand
reasonably well how Stellar furnaces
ultimately can cook some of the heavier
nuclei Like Oxygen spewed out into space
with Supernova explosions hydrogen
oxygen they co-mingle we understand that
process but it still is a mystery about
Earth's water per se right early Earth
went through Piers where it was very hot
you imagine any
original water would have evaporated no
atmosphere to hold it in so what is the
thinking on where Earth's water came
from
that's a that is the question
uh there's there's a lot of work that's
gone into studying Earth's water and um
the major contributors to it uh as you
said
Earth's history has been so chaotic the
survival of this much water that we have
here today
um was just it doesn't work with the
numbers uh the way that you would
anticipate it should
um there's a lot of consideration
whether or not it's geologic processing
so water heavy Elemental material or
otherwise coming up from subsurface sort
of seeping from our mantle
um whether or not it's delivered and
delivery could be from you know the
small meteoritic material or inner
planetary dust or from small bodies
comets come into the solar system
they're known to have a lot of water and
that was the original thought for a long
time was because bombardment yeah
they're the primary source of water in
the solar system it's a huge Reservoir
and the Kuiper belt and the Oort cloud
maybe you can just remind people of
Kuiper Belden so we have two small body
regions tons of bodies in the solar
system I can actually do a diagram here
laughs so uh stepping out from the sun
which would be me uh you have Mercury
Venus Earth uh Mars and then you have
the asteroid belt so that's the first
reservoir of small bodies small bodies
we think are the sort of the cookie
crumbs of when the solar system formed
then you have your uh giant planets and
your um ice the ice giants and then
beyond that you have the Kuiper belt
and then beyond the Kuiper belt there's
believed to be that work Cloud which is
still a theory we haven't detected it
yet but we believe in this work Cloud
because sometimes we get comets that
come from very extreme
um eccentricities as they come into the
inner solar system and so the reservoir
has been sort of hypothesized but we
also believe that that's where a lot of
our new comets actually come from so
these big hillbops uh or yakitaki kind
of comets or let me think of one more
recent uh Comet ice on for the younger
folks in the room
and it does potentially make sense that
that commas could have delivered all of
Earth's water or that's a big question
well I thought there was an issue with
deuterium exactly yeah okay yeah so um
one of the ways that we've been trying
to get evidence of whether cometary
water could have been a source is by
studying the deuterium of our hydrogen
ratio so Earth's water has a known
deuterium and hydrogen ratio that's
pretty consistent across the entire
planet and all the water reservoirs
um and so the belief is if if comets
were the primary source then they should
have a deuterium the hydrogen ratio what
is deuterium deuterium is heavy
hydrogens so you have an X Neutron on
the on the molecule
molecule and edit so deuterium
is just a heavy form of water so we call
it heavy water
um at any rate so we we're trying to
gain evidence to see whether the
deuterium to hydrogen ratio and comets
coming from this very cold outer belt
region in the solar system actually had
a ratio that matched Earth's ocean
the problem is is measuring the
deuterium to hydrogen ratio you have to
have extreme sensitivity the right
wavelength coverage and access to
comments we only get fantastically
bright comets every uh once every couple
years and you need the signal or a lot
of flux to be able to detect a deuterium
isotope ratio because it's like one in
ten thousand that you need and then you
need a good signal to noise to have a
you know a firm confidence in what that
ratio actually is
um water is very hard to observe from
earth mostly because
there's a lot of water in our atmosphere
so if you're using a telescope on Earth
and you're trying to detect water
you have to look through the Earth's
atmosphere
so we have tricks that we use so comets
are moving pretty fast so that helps us
because it kind of shifts the velocity
of the wavelengths so all of the
emission lines shift to different
velocities because of the relative speed
of the object coming or going
um and so that's that's a very helpful
trick but we still don't have access to
a lot of the fundamental lines and it's
very challenging
other observatories that have been
launched into space are very sensitive
to water we had the Herschel space
Observatory for example that was from
the European space agency that was
designed to basically look for water not
only in the solar system but um in
star-forming regions disc and Across the
Universe
and um we only had a couple of comets
that actually came by that were strong
enough or bright enough that we could
actually study the deuterium ratio
and the one comment that we got very
good data on with that Observatory
suggested that we had a deuterium to
hydrogen ratio that was equivalent to
Earth's ocean and that was very
compelling that was very exciting and we
thought that was going to be sort of a
tick in the box of you know this is
really definitive evidence of Earth's
oceans
but the problem is is usually the
comments that we observe again have to
be big and bright they have to be and
the right part of the sky at the right
time we have to have access to
telescopes you can't have weather
blocking your telescope at night and
we're competing with you know the extra
Galactic scientists that are studying
you know the cosmic microwave background
so um it's it's very competitive and
getting time on this guy with the right
telescope with the right weather it it
all has to work perfectly because comets
come and go we we don't
we don't get to go back to the same part
of the sky in six months and it's going
to be there it's going away and
sometimes they completely disintegrate
and disappear
so we have a challenge in statistics of
how many we can actually do this with
and so there's about a dozen or uh
there's about 20 now that we've measured
this ratio in and the ratios vary
anything from Earth's ocean
instance of one and a half and then most
of them are about a factor of two and so
that's a big problem for trying to
connect the deuterium to hydrogen ratio
now whether or not all of Earth's ocean
came from a small body some component
could have come from interior structure
and maybe that's the influence that
we're seeing some blending of the
sources yeah and it's likely a
combination of all the different
processes but it is a very challenging
problem and it's something that the
James Webb's face telescope is
fortunately going to help us with not
only do we have the wavelength coverage
being in the infrared where we can see
the actual emission of water vapor as
well as carbon dioxide carbon monoxide
all these sort of building blocks of
critical very fundamental biochemistry
so the sources of oxygen the hydrogen
carbon that we would think would enable
initiation of some sort of organic or
Prebiotic chemistry
um we now know that comets also have
Prebiotic molecules in them due to the
Rosetta Mission
um we detected Glycine and confirmed it
in the Rosetta comet and we also had
samples returned from a comment from the
Stardust mission where glycine was also
detected so this is really provocative
to think that these bodies not only
brought or Associated and you know or
the water to Earth but now they also
have all this other really peculiar and
interesting organic chemistry
yeah so getting back to the the
statistics jwst has the wavelength
coverage but it also has the sensitivity
and this is something we're learning
every single day with this telescope it
is so much better than we anticipated
and we are studying objects in the outer
solar system with levels of detail that
you can only let your mind wander
um to now seeing comments as they're
coming into the solar system and
measuring that water ratio deuterium is
still pretty hard we're going to have to
hit a little harder than what we've
already done so far with the James Webb
Space Telescope but we're getting there
so it's still an open question then of
exactly where Earth's water came from
you recently had a result where you
found water in a unusual a Heavenly Body
an unusual location right yes can you
just give us a sense of that and that
result and this is actually going to
contribute to our story about our
supporters so
um we detect we um
there's a lot of history to this
particular observation if you want to
know those details we can go into it so
we decided to point the telescope at
something called a main belt Comet so
these there's about a dozen of these
objects that live in the asteroid belt
again just where's the asteroid belt the
one that's between Mars
I'm not sure just to be clear between
Mars and Jupiter uh that's the asteroid
belt and there's about a dozen of these
objects that they don't look like
asteroids they look like comets
comets look very different than
asteroids because they have what we call
a coma so they're very fuzzy in
appearance and that's because volatiles
from
embedded within the object itself
once those ices actually get warm enough
they sublimate they turn into gas and
that's basically the difference right
asteroid Rocky Comet icy right yes yes
um
comets still have a lot of dust within
them and that's actually what you mostly
see when you look at Optical images of
comets
when this gas is coming off it pools a
lot of that dust with it and so that
gives us an optical wavelengths this
fuzzy
smudge that you would see if you were
looking through just your own telescope
um but there's these objects in the
asteroid belt that should not have ice
embedded within them they're they're way
too close to the Sun
and they don't have an atmosphere to
protect them so that any ice that would
be on the surface or close to the
surface would you would assume just be
completely depleted it's just too hot
everything boils off it's like Mars so
and Mars is even big enough that it can
actually gravitationally hold a 10 U.S
atmosphere and so some of it actually
gets protected and it's got these
fantastic poles in the North and South
that are protected from direct heat and
radiation
comets not so much they Tumble They're
spinning and they're constantly getting
close to Sun or other sources of heat
and
why there would be any water or anything
that would drive activity on these
objects was always a mystery
we used every big telescope you can
imagine to look at these objects
everything from you say there's like 12
of them did you say there's about a
dozen yeah
large optical telescopes infrared
telescopes on the ground Hubble has
looked at them we've been trying to
detect whether or not they had any
volatiles within them that we could that
would be driving this activity and
making them look like a comet and it
took the sensitivity and the wavelength
coverage of the James Webb Space
Telescope to detect water vapor in one
of these objects and that's huge that's
that means there's water being preserved
in the asteroid belt so statistically
speaking if we're thinking of small
bodies that are going to hit a
terrestrial planet the asteroids are a
heck of a lot closer than comets there's
a lot more of them that are close by
yeah so if they collide with one another
and get kicked off course one coming
close to Earth or even hitting Earth
would definitely be much more probable
than waiting for a comet coming from the
outer solar system and can you show us
the data do you have yeah do we have the
well this is actually a jwc image but
here's the Spectra yeah so this is
um what we do when we're doing
spectroscopy is we're looking for
fingerprints of given molecules so every
molecule has a fingerprint That's Unique
you have a different fingerprint than me
so if we wanted to look for you in space
we would look for your fingerprints
versus if you wanted to look for me
so what you're seeing here is the actual
spectrum that we were able to acquire of
um this Comet uh it's 238p uh read it's
a main belt Comet compared to uh data
that we got from a flyby mission of
comet 103p Hartley 2. that particular
spacecraft had an infrared spectrometer
on it and it was studying the Deep
Impact Mission but also this secondary
mission of flying by this this other
Comet and it has a very standard Comet
Spectra so it's the one on the top and
the blue Trace so you see the water
emission feature
um showing you where the water would be
picked up with respect to a main Comet
and then you can see where the jwst data
the white line actually falls right in
line with where the water emission was
for other comets
um so that was beyond exciting as soon
as I saw this data I was jumping out of
my seat I ran over to the pi and I was
like we have you have the paper written
today right and
um he kind of laughed at me and then
every time I saw him for two months I
antagonized him about writing his paper
um because this is a huge science result
this means there's water in the asteroid
belt as I said but what was also very
peculiar about these data is there's no
carbon dioxide
every comment we've ever looked at it
infrared wavelengths that had access to
measuring CO2 it's always there and it's
very prominent it's a very easy molecule
detect and it is not in this object so
this gives us a whole different puzzle
on the formation of the solar system
preservation of volatile material and
how mixed all of these objects actually
really were so when Jupiter and was
migrating from the Sun during the early
formation it kicked around a lot of
these cookie crumbs of the solar system
so the comets and the asteroids got
knocked all about and it mixed them up
in in ways that we can simulate a model
and we think we understand but if you
look at other formation processes we
can't quite explain it with the same
model
and now we have to be able to explain
how water can be preserved embedded
within a rocky body in the main belt
without carbon dioxide which potentially
can be explained by just chemistry
but they're usually one and one they're
right together and they're preserved in
the same sort of reservoirs so is it
because we have sort of some water
component that's been preserved in this
body and we have a heterogeneous nucleus
or Body Solid body or has all the carbon
dioxide just been heated and sublimated
out earlier
whatever it is it's beyond our detection
limit so far with the James Webb Space
but do you have any ideas any theories
models for how the water could still be
there
not really
um it would have to be like the
Goldilocks zone of Planet formation or
um during that period so when we look at
disks when we're studying other planet
formation and Stellar Evolution uh
observationally we can see where water
starts freezing out in these discs and
where you have sort of a region of what
we call hot water
um but when it gets too close that's
when the star is too hot and the water
just becomes completely annihilated
um so it'd have to be in a really
particular region and it would have to
be preserved
immediately
there's other ice lines so water turns
to ice at certain temperatures carbon
dioxide turns to ice at certain
temperatures and carbon monoxide turns
to ice at certain temperatures and we
see these ice lines observationally and
we we study them we're trying to
understand
yes
and so um it tells us a lot of
information about what what chemistry is
going on what are the ingredients that
would form a planet in those zones
because Earth would need to have some
contribution of water and so was it
Formed within its Ice Line or Beyond it
if not how is that water brought so this
this is sort of the Enigma that we're
trying to and do you think that this is
just sort of um an odd anomaly that just
happened to happen or is it pointing
towards something deeper I think it's
pointing at something deeper we knew it
was already peculiar because it looked
like a comet right we just couldn't
detect anything Comet like about it
Beyond it being fuzzy so now we got time
next year to go to a couple more of
these objects with James Webb Space
Telescope and study them deeper right
um really try to push on the carbon
dioxide because we we're very puzzled
about the carbon dioxide and we want a
good upper limit and constraint on that
but also we want to go to the longer
wavelengths of the James Webb Space
Telescope where we can look at the dust
and what that's com composed of uh we
already know in asteroids that the dust
can vary we have sort of families of
different kinds of dust and minerals
that are contained in these in these
bodies and so understanding whether or
not a main belt comets dust looks like
an asteroid dust or does it look like
meteoritic dust and what that all means
in the in the long run so there's a lot
to do this is just a completely
tantalizing and
um just poking all of the commentary
scientists and planetary Evolution folks
with a stick and so
you mentioned
with respect to our solar system the
Oort cloud kuiperville main belt
asteroids is that
a quality that you see repeated in other
planetary systems yes so so we do see um
free disc
the sensitivity and fantastic technology
that's happened for ground-based
telescopes at all weighing blinks and
even space-based telescopes we're we've
been able to start resolving discs but
um for the first time we've actually
been able to image an asteroid belt of a
disc and that's what we actually
released a couple of weeks ago so this
is the formal hot observation fomo hot
with James Webb Space Telescope so this
is mid infrared emission of a planetary
disk and it is uh and where is it like
how far away is this oh 10 000 light
years or so I think
um so it
it is a very well studied and well-known
uh disc we've observed it with every big
telescope you can imagine at all the
wavelengths and we've always known about
this beautiful outer ring that you see
um we've characterized it we know where
the ice lines are within this disc
um and we've even had resolution to do
sensitive searches embedded within the
disc to try to find planets that are
actually forming so little clumps of
material that would suggest that a
planet is actually being born within
this disc because you can see that the
Rings are actually separated which means
something is eating the material within
that given radius and so we believe
that's how planets are forming and
they're consuming that dust and material
in those in those rings
um there was a lump that was identified
in this object
um a number of years ago I believe it
was with
I think it was the VLT
um so the very large telescope and it
was a clump of material in one of these
outer rings and
um
we've done a number of studies and
observations to try to follow this and
see whether or not it actually looks
like a planet or a planet nucleus but
the jwst data is looking more like it
was a collision so maybe some major
bodies
um
probably scales of like
uh Pluto size actually colliding and
interacting so it's looking more like
debris now as opposed to a solid body
which is very intriguing or it's a
background Galaxy spectroscopy is the
only way to reveal that and we are doing
the spectroscopy now on the subject with
jwst
that team is working really hard on
trying to get those observations done so
overall would you say that our solar
system is run-of-the-mill generic or is
it
special so far it's Unique
but we do have
um distinct Rings uh debris rings that
we do see in other systems uh the the
Fantastic part about the jwst results
for this particular object is this is
the first time the inner rink and region
has actually been observed and detected
we believed it was there because of this
Gap that you see it's nice and clear on
the inside of that outer ring but we've
never been able to detect it and it took
the sensitivity and resolution of jwc to
detect this asteroid belt and then even
inside of that belt um
depending on the version of the image
that you look at at the different
wavelengths you can see there's also an
inner ring you can almost see it on the
lower left hand side that there's also
another sort of Gap there so this is a
really intriguing result
so we see these rings and other
planetary systems we're trying to find
the planets embedded within them it's
proving to be very very challenging but
I think I think jwst is going to get us
there and if you do get there then even
if our solar system shows certain unique
features the existence of these belts
with that suggest that water drenched
worlds would not be
anomalous that they could potentially
apply water in much the same way that we
did from asteroids in some version of
their asteroids so that's that'll be the
next step is sort of getting the
Spectrum going across these objects
seeing where those ice lines are seeing
where Planet formation that we believe
to be forming in these objects
then understanding whether that volatile
material could be transported where it
would have started nucleated and how
Planet migration as the planets evolve
and kick these things all around how
that material gets stirred up and that's
going to take a lot of simulations
obviously but the more observational
data we get the better we do with those
things and understand them now returning
to Enceladus
you mentioned earlier about you know
this wonderful Insight regarding a
watery World underneath a crust an icy
crust
when we talk about life on planet Earth
nobody really knows how or where it
began but one of the ideas that
certainly gained a lot of traction is
that hot thermal vents on the ocean
floor may be the place where Organics
came together in wonderful plumes and
ultimately generated the first
ingredients necessary for life
that might suggest that life on the
surface of a planet maybe that's
relatively rare and anomalous maybe it's
all underneath so what does that lead
you to think about these these water
worlds of the form that intelligence and
others that we know are out there yeah
that's that's
um so we have a mission that we're
getting ready to launch next year it's
called the Europa Clipper Mission so
it's going to Europa which is one of the
satellites of Jupiter that has again an
icy crust and we believe has the
subsurface ocean
so plumes of gas have been detected um
not continuously in the same way that
Enceladus has been done so it's more
elusive they've
it's kind of been we've been in the
right place at the right time to see
them and
some people are still pretty skeptical
about whether or not there is plume
activity on Europa
um and so
Enceladus we know the plumes are driven
mostly by
um it's it's got sort of an elliptical
orbit around Saturn so the gravitational
pull kind of squishes the water
um and so you know you can imagine it
almost breathing and then little bursts
of water coming out and
um we should be able to see those
enhancements in the ring itself when we
get the full Spectra across Saturn's
rings
um but that's that's something that
we've also simulated with these data and
understand
Europa is a different case
um
the plumes have been fortuitous we we
keep trying to understand what could
drive them what would be the instigator
of this there's been a lot of hypotheses
about internal process generation of
heat or thermal vents or whatever
and so it's just come down to now we're
just sending a spacecraft there to
really do a thorough study yeah
um we want to see one if there's any
evidence across the surface of like uh
you can imagine when a volcano erupts
and all of the magma kind of gets
pushed onto the surface you get this
fantastic evidence that something came
from somewhere else we also see these on
what we call
uh
there's like icy volcanoes that do this
as well and we see that we saw evidence
of this on Pluto with the New Horizons
Mission
um so this cryovolcanism type process so
it's just something very very cold that
comes out and it freezes it's not magma
um and so we want to look for evidence
of that across the surface and with a
really fine-tooth comb so being in an
orbit around it and getting a full up
close map we hope to see some evidence
of that compositional studies again
worsening magnetometers we want to know
how what the mass of the inside of this
is compared to you know the rest of the
body and I think we'll get a lot more
insight
ideally you want to send a probe to one
of these objects and if it were my pick
I would obviously go to Enceladus just
because it's continuous plume activity
and we've monitored it in ways that we
haven't been able to do with Europa yet
and so wonderfully the James Webb has a
long life ahead of it much longer than
even was initially thought in the early
stages
hopefully and likely you have a long
life ahead of you as well part of it
will be devoted to
analyzing the data of jwst but what do
you see as the the big prize the Big
Goal going forward for yourself would it
be discovering life on another world is
is that the the the big end game or is
there something else well there is life
on other worlds there's even life in our
solar system beyond the Earth because we
put it there
um we weren't very good about cleaning
things and
yeah for a moment I had no idea what you
were talking about
I thought we were going to Crazy places
but yeah so contamination is definitely
a concern that I have and something that
I'm actually a big advocate for
um for all agencies to start really
considering what we're sending
spacecraft to and how
um especially as the commercial industry
starts growing
um there's no protocol on what we're
doing and so every time we land
somewhere there's no protocol
um no prime directive kind of thing
that's NASA's trying some agencies are
trying but Private Industry doesn't seem
to really blink an eye about these
things
it's a lot of investment it's a lot of
time and it
prolongs your program because you have
to be clean about it
um and so there's been a number of
studies that have been done about you
know what are the objects that we don't
care to preserve and is there a
statistical sample of them and right so
we're running numbers on these things so
so if the commercial industry wants to
start mining asteroids do we care uh
kind of a thing and there's obvious
objects that don't ever touch them with
your dirty equipment because we really
want to know if there's some potential
for life and the more we contaminate a
body the more
confusing evidence will be for finding
something like a microorganism or even
fossilized life
so uh
I I uh my quest is
um honestly Comet sample return
I really want to know what this ice is
and I want to know what the ice is on
the inside of the body as a comet comes
around it gets its sunburned as it gets
close to the sun and it gets a little
bit cooked the same way I do because I'm
so white
um and that gives you sort of this outer
layer of the object that that's cooked
and all the preserved pristine
non-processed stuff is sort of on the
interior and that I really really really
want to get my hands on it we have such
sophisticated equipment here on Earth
that we could really get into the
details of what how complex that
chemistry is what that ice actually
looks like is there salts is there uh
more complex biochemistry or Prebiotic
molecules like we see in meteorites for
example
um and that's going to take a
considerable amount of effort and energy
to get a cryogenic mission to a small
body collect a sample beneath the
surface and cryogenically bring it back
to Earth
not to mention Earth entry landing and
descent it has to survive all of that
and stay cold so it's really difficult
so what really what drives the passion
to know this information I think there's
a lot of information embedded Within
These objects I mean we're already
learning so much about the sample
returns coming from even the moon lunar
rocks um to what we're doing with
asteroids we're bringing samples back
from a new asteroid in uh two months so
the osiris-rex mission will be returning
at samples and we're going to get a
whole new grasp of what that molecular
inventory actually looks like on a body
that's already been cooked so the
asteroids are the cooked ones of the
solar system so that's really exciting
and compelling and we already know that
other asteroid sample return has has
already brought a lot of promise for the
complexity that's embedded in these
objects so the the question that I have
is a chemist and a planetary scientist
is
the meteoritic molecular complexity was
that something that happened during the
process of that meteorite
this is an asteroid or meteoroid that
has to come into Earth it usually
boloids a lot of it's annihilated in the
upper atmosphere
and only the tiny little fragments of it
that survive and actually touch the
Earth are the ones that we collect yeah
and there's the key it touches the Earth
so we already know there's life here on
Earth we already know there's a sense of
contamination to be considered in these
objects we try to study objects that
have been dropped in Antarctica there's
a lot less
um concern about contamination but there
is still some there and so
um that's what these asteroid sample
returns are sort of giving us that
Insight of what's the pristine nature
what's the parent body that actually
created the meteorites
um and then understanding how that
chemistry has actually evolved and was
it during this falling and descent
process or is it something that happened
on the asteroid and how would an
asteroid compare to a comet so um if I
got my couple billion dollars to do what
I wanted to do I bring a sample back to
Earth well those are wonderfully clear
priorities and I hope that one day at
least you get insight to the molecular
chemical structure of these fascinating
bodies so join me in thanking Stephanie
Milam
[Music]
thank you